es el hombre de todos los récords el
único en haber ganado seis balones de
oro leo messi ganador de 35 trofeos como
capitán entre esos cuatro trofeos de la
liga de campeones de la uefa y según
muchos el mejor jugador de todos los
tiempos pero antes de convertirse en una
verdadera leyenda sus primeros pasos
fueron en esta modesta casa de rosario
la tercera ciudad más grande de
argentina su padre obrero y su madre ama
de casa no inscriben a un club de fútbol
de la ciudad a los cinco años
rápidamente comienza a impresionar por
sus capacidades en la cancha en 2014 el
entrenador de sus inicios recuerda
aquella época
una diablura con la pelota que llevaba
atada tenía una velocidad de los francos
cortitos que él tiene
y con qué facilidad pasaba jugadores
pero rápidamente lío se enfrentó a un
problema de altura a los nueve años
media tan sólo un metro 27 centímetros
me acuerdo de cnn tan chiquitito tan
diminuto que necesitaba no sé de lo
abrazaran borg era muy tímido los
médicos le diagnosticaron un déficit en
hormonas del crecimiento una enfermedad
que habría podido arruinar sus sueños en
la cancha de fútbol sin contar con el
carácter del jugador su médico de la
época recuerdo a un niño que se negaba a
rendirse el de ppl siempre decía si va a
crecer como para jugar al fútbol que
quería jugar y yo les llamo quédate
tranquilo qué vas a hacer más alto que
maradona no sé si vas a ser mejor pero
vas a ser más alto durante varios años
lío messi pasó por largos y costosos
procesos que implicaban inyecciones de
hormonas tratamiento que fue costeado
por el fc barcelona equipo al que se
unió en su adolescencia y en el que
vivió una historia apasionante de 20
años de la que leo messi se despidió
emotivamente
ahora será con otra camiseta que
perpetuará su legado como leyenda